you just take a picture or something
no people need to get the full sense of
how you're doing well if you're filming
me then you better at least that good
news it's not good news
James can you hold it for me I want to
tell you what camera is he like yeah
okay okay
the doctors have spoken and in three
days
so Claire's still a massive bitch
which one's Claire supervisor yeah
I just have no me time cuz she's just
working me constantly at the overtime
pay is nice there yeah I guess you still
want to find somewhere else
eventually you are going to that uni one
today right uh no oh I know I'm sorry
you know I got in but I told you already
I'm not doing uni anymore I'm taking a
gap here oh right
you like the inscription
very tasteful
Gabby is a great idea I'm gonna do a
trip or something like Africa Shanny
went to Burma before uni really opened
our mind or whatever should do it
please be quiet sorry conscience pretend
like nothing's happened okay yeah I'm
just trying to help
yeah well you know what would actually
help let me think about him stop it I
want to be sad okay I mean have you
cried at all yet I know you're not over
already
it's been almost a year
marry look you're gonna be fine
we just have to stay strong do it from
mum yeah cuz you know so much about
looking after her that's not fair
no James ET s'en the only person you
need to worry about is you I'm putting
my whole life on hold for mum she
doesn't even want me to but I have to do
it because I know she needs someone who
do I have now exactly look I'm trying
I'm here now cuz clearly you've made me
feel notes better what you'd rather he
looks after you
you should try learning to look after
yourself it would have been better for
him if you'd have done that in the first
place
sorry
yes now I know what you think of me
that's not true
I
it wasn't in phone
if anything it was the doctors they let
him out too early maybe
I could have helped it though if I
hadn't stayed out so late that night you
hadn't have needed him to come and pick
me up then you wouldn't have ended up I
don't blame you for hating me
you want to go
just give me a minute
you
oh my god hi cäcilie
thank used to it I went to see Elliot
this morning someone who works at the
cemetery told me off for trying to leave
cake again though can we talk about him
not now
why not I don't feel like it
are you
you